Joe Biden was just asked what he is  doing about the Border here's Biden's  answer  because they're more important thing  going on they're going to invest  billions of dollars in a new Enterprise  we got bigger problems this is a major  problem according to public opinion  polls if you look at public opinion  polls right now the issue of immigration  is important to everybody not just  Republicans Democrats too the majority  of Americans want to drastically reduce  all immigration to the United States Mr  President you're flooding the country  with two million illegals every single  year yeah we got bigger problems  whatever moving on what are you going to  do to me